what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stopped being polite and start
getting real this is the champion
I keep scenes and knees like their boss
uzuki paws like their boss I am so
pumped to join Chelsea because I was in
danger of actually winning things at
Dortmund and that would go against
everything the US men's national team
believes in every time we gets a bad
result I take a hard look in the mirror
and that blames officials to win the cut
of the grass the smells of the stadium
here and back and winning is in my genes
[Music]
nice to finally build of that set oh hey
Cristiano not to be that guy but would
you send my Ronaldo Jersey
of course is very tiny oh it's from when
I was a baby when you were a baby oh my
god you're like a man now and you are a
legend merci Mon Ami a legend like Raoul
or pelé or Figo legends are old no a
mile
oh thank you for seeing me doctor
Iceland guy I'm having an emergency Oh
No did you chip a tooth what no my teeth
are perfect I hear because I think I'm
aging I don't think he understands what
a dentist does Christiano you have the
body of a 23 year old who hunt III know
just a year ago all the doctors say I
have body of 22 year olds now he tells
me 23 this is more serious than I
thought I thought it best to seek out
advice from another Juventus legend one
who has suffered for many years with the
aging aging-- is nothing to fear I have
been 50 years old since I was 25 it's
just scary to think that one day I might
not be the best player in the world
maybe it's time for you to take a long
look in the beer oh nice do you have a
mirror no what I mean is do you expect
to play this game forever
yeah nobody can play this game forever
you are mortal you can die you're going
to get old you are going to die so at
this point I'm like for someone known
for his passes and Dreier can be quite a
straight shooter so so what am I gonna
have to like retire someday not yet
you still up a few years with the old
lady what do you mean old lady Georgina
is 25 I mean you Vento's okay but then
what then you do what all the former
elite players do are you an aging soccer
or sorry football star in Europe come
join MLS where you can score three goals
a game make hundreds of millions of
dollars and you won't get bothered on
the streets because no one will
recognize you know the US dollar may be
worth less than euros and pounds in MLS
you may be forced to play defense and
take commercial flights also everyone
guns come on over it's actually more
challenging than you think believe me oh
god I need to go
hello where's Ronaldo I'm so scared
please tell me retirement will be okay
oh no it's great you get to eat whatever
you want
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion if you
need a cross into the box pray you have
an aunt Helen your wing money can't buy
you silverware is what the Chairman
keeps telling me don't hate me because
I'm beautiful
hate me because I had a great world cup
five years ago and not much else
I'm not the new canard oh I'm the first
valve easiest oh except for vanity a
senior
[Music]
hey you guys sorry Garrett's a bailed
but thanks for taking the rest of us out
now you are just like your season tell a
legal tradition every night we all get
dinner at 11:00 p.m. and go to the club
till about 3:00 a.m. which makes us
perfectly ready for breakfast at noon
and then match it 1 and 1 do you want
red or white mm-hmm I used to wear that
shirt do you know the little magician
show you how it's done guys excuse me um
could you yeah would you mind keeping it
down please
I mean whoo sleeves that much what
planet is he for come on Garrett for
once have fun with us slow down you know
I have a problem with conversational
Spanish we are speaking English to you
we just have accents I don't know why I
haven't been able to pretend I've even
learned all the Spanish I need I mean go
ahead test me okay call most us haste Oy
hurry doh que pasa
a story herido okay sounds like what a
transfer well-read not cool man oh oh no
I'm sorry I it's just I need to be at my
best for tomorrow's big match big match
we are out of the Champions League and
the Copa del Rey and right now we only
play the La Liga matches to get out of
the house once in a while oh no no no my
big golf match I'm trying to beat my
personal best unless you want to join
anyone all right well see you later
what's that socks we have a lot of
nicknames for Garrett like the Martian
because we don't like him the golfer
because we don't like him more like less
good Renaldo because we don't like him I
don't know something's off with him man
nobody in the right mind wouldn't want
to hang out with us maybe he wants a
true maybe he's faking an injury I know
let's go through his stuff to find out
what he's hiding
because maybe instead go to sleep and
practice more so we stop losing
disguise I found something
why is dispenser so small I'm scared he
really is a now CI what's going on is it
is it tea time already
get away from my failure you're
different and will hate you
but that's just my welsh books like golf
pencils and my exfoliating mask please
pour for haul oh now you speak Spanish I
tried to fit in but after six years it's
clear I am the only true Galactic okay
I don't belong at Real Madrid it's time
for me to go home
[Music]
I will stick with red thank you guys
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
player stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion
despite recent results we already got
the historic quadruple of this season we
were investigated by you weigh 50 by the
FA in the Premier League
I followed in the footsteps of the
greats by leaving Southampton you think
a card is a dog I shagged me Brutus mr.
right and that's all we need thank you
for coming in mr. Giggs
[Music]
it's late good guy why did hurricane
text us to choose him in the backyard
for a crashing wood crime nothing to be
scared of Phil it's just a tent I'm not
scared
this is my happy face and Irwin welcome
[Music]
wunderbar
this must have taken you all weekend
yeah again come in come in I thought
we'd have a casual day baking it's so oh
my it looks like the toilet say hello
remember me I'm asked and I am the
special one welcome to the great british
baking table
while we're all optimistic when it comes
to a big game Spurs have a tendency to
be rather Spurs that's the word so I ask
myself if I were British and want to win
a trophy what would I do
so I organized a baking competition now
every competition is judges so I found
the most judgmental and also out of work
people that I know and to ensure that we
win I've had the boys practicing baking
for weeks now hopefully this works and
we should win because after all we are
the only team ready for this yeah we are
ready for this oh let's have more
resources than I do
oh wow the purple spies have somehow
been impressive all season but something
tells me they will step up in defiance
just a fun day out he said no stress he
said all of a sudden I'm under a lot of
pressure to score all these pies come on
we need to go higher I fear we may have
reached our ceiling tottenham amazing a
totem cake which is pink and fun but
also crumbly and fragile now what is
really immensity we'll be making a
perfect Manchester Taj for the literal
cheerio I'm having the finest maraschino
cherries brownie around a private jet
well just so happy to have you on our
team for their signature baked
Manchester United are making a huge
mistake
seriously they think he's garden gnome
of a managers better than me to be
honest I really thought when we hosted
this competition that the other clubs
they had like little to no baking
experience but as it turns out they are
taking this very seriously so guys you
need to focus on the finish of
Lancashire Rose's 9320 of them come on
put more pressure on it slow
hmm these all appear to be top quality
lawyer
I won't taste them because I know they
are not as good as the Chelsea buns I
made three times in fourth and last
place you you you and especially you Pau
you should all be disappointed both
places nice take it from me it is the
same as a trophy okay but come on
Harry's ankle has been through so much
it is there something for his baking
contributions okay fine whatever
hurricane you are here by a member of
the most excellent Order of the baking
Empire hyeri's been awarded MBE
[Music]
[Music]
so how do we beat Liverpool on the pitch
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion I'm
one of the best players in the world
according to my HIV people say I would
be good in the Premier League but first
I need to be good in Syria thanks Kappa
but we actually need a Champions League
goalkeeper so let's cut the crap
this was bad disco beat all right I
can't sleep I haven't slept since that
day we were in total control then he
took it away my question is we decided
on the sizes of the paintings
[Music]
no and one you are not an end what you
only need to harness in your heart come
on let's talk somewhere else that
doesn't smell like a port-o-potty look
you're great and one your hair deserves
to be up there with the legends but do
you why not I'm just as good as fun all
done messy at what I won the World Cup
Oh Popeye won the world
shut up Infinite
the book no one reads okay so apparently
there's some kind of secret Fight Club
going on in the basement yeah so we
never told anyone about the secret Fight
Club because he's always got thousands
of Governments following him oh wait
[ __ ] the first rule of Fight letter go
is you do not talk about Fight Latika
unless a streaming service offers you a
lot of money I don't got it like how
much money the second rule of Fight Leto
is if you do talk about my let it go
because a streaming service offered to a
lot of money don't take tax advice from
your family
smells so seriously like how much money
the third rule of Fight Club to get a
red card for violent conduct is easy to
get your opponent sent off for doing
nothing that is the work of a true ask
this is the real muttley at Roulette the
toaster I know I'm not the not led to go
player but they told me they had a safe
space for violence oh yes please
[Music]
[Music]
I'm okay now you gotta play to the
whistle after hey what's going on
tough guys grabbing your cojones this is
you this is what you look like and this
is what you look like
I knocked you out of the Champions
League and I can knock you over here
I did okay I didn't touch him stop Shh
stop shaking your head disapprovingly
people love me
you all love me right cool man show a
really really good-looking talented chef
Wow you are shameless
hi Emma legend legends news trophies
okay bye
good fight what did you say about me
Madre
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers compete in one musical variety
show welcome to a very special episode
of the champ new vision I am your host
Sergio Ramos let's get started with our
first half since real one last year I've
been forced to host the UEFA vision okay
so why you and now on your teammates
don't want me here pay me I'll live we
are messy we are pursue these are fake
titties are when we are not blowing
three gold leads we are we are messy or
we are messy it's time to show this time
to show that we are so much better than
Christina Rosa
ladies and gentlemen my wife Shakira
[Applause]
game what we need Spurs a look at jokes
put those two games at a time and your
fastball leave the second you choke
now it's transfer time we go Josh
so how was IX I skipped the second half
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
well pay pay who would have guessed
so sort of hoping that since I'm leaving
I wouldn't have to join Dortmund on
stage let's just say the German
performances can get pretty out there
you like our yellow ball now face our
wall of noise
[Music]
Santa Lucia shoka no fear
Cindy can happen
[Music]
[Music]
next up Atletico the poor man's Madrid
singing for us will be my best friend
Drake Philip in my dance but think I'm
gonna blockers my chant socks honey
Amaya watching Sarkis they wanna go to
club but I can't god forbid his Lord
knows I'm a big supporter huh
Atletico Madrid wait that letter goes
out who's in Liverpool sir yeah growing
up in Canada I've always been a huge fan
of Liverpool and that was PSG
demonstrating why teamwork is important
and now for something completely
different
too many English teams
that's the same crap they played last
year why do you think they have a chance
this time
[Music]
he's good yeah
[Music]
so magic
so
funny how
it's gone
oh wait so he can sing in English but he
only speaks Spanish I don't get it I'll
be jostled man
together with one man United no their
Josie is gone I came in like a [ __ ]
ok ladies and gentlemen once again
Shakira
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]